hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play RasPi hill
okay so I got a lot of emails that said
that I needed to play this because there
were mannequins in this and if you know
me you know that I do not like
mannequins at all alright even though I
have reservations about this I'm gonna
play it anyway because it's gonna be
entertaining for you to watch so hooray
for me I'm actually in the game right
now and I think it said left
oh okay I think it said left click to
move so I'm not sure I'm not sure what
else I can do in the game what is that
sound
Oh
okay all right oh hello oh hi okay all
right I get it I need to run hahahaha
Oh God you know it soon it's not that
you know it's not that necessarily
mannequins are scary to me it's just
that they're creepy and if you don't
know the difference you really should
check out vsauce is great video about
the difference between creepy and what
the hell is that I've no idea
ah Wow the trap oh my god there's so
many of them does it put the lights in
ur
kind of appearing why holy crap I'm
gonna get a WoW the Bobby from the
friggin sky uh-huh oh god they're so
creepy oh god they're so creepy Oh what
are these grapes don't sit good did he
say oh my god don't like it away get
away get away get away
I don't quite feel like myself I've been
having strange dreams lately but now
you're here and I'll make you feel right
at home
welcome to raspy Hill
enjoy your stay